this is Startalk
okay Gavin Buscher asks for he's from
Melbourne Australia he asked do you
lament the lack of funding not just for
NASA but for science education in
general from a distance the other side
of the world it appears that America's
school science programs are not
receiving the backing that they should
and are under attack from other
influences such as religious and
political agendas if I were king it is
yes we would have more funding for
science but if I may let's not call it
Channel but speak on behalf of my
beloved colleague Neil deGrasse Tyson
who would normally be hosting star talk
radio if we had a robust space program
where investment was being made at a
higher level than it is now and we were
going to someplace new and cool with
people like mass flying out into space
someplace new and exciting you wouldn't
need to run in circles screaming about
science technology engineering and math
which we like to call stem it would just
happen it would be it would be the real
trickle-down of science that is a real
thing though it would well not just
science but exploration right adventure
and exactly because there's two things
that happen Mass you've been up there
you've done it you when you go exploring
two things you get you're going to make
discoveries you're going to find things
you never found before the other thing
you're going to have Eugene yeah and
yeah adventure adventure oh yeah did you
guys when you were in space did you
discover anything were you were you like
oh this is a thing nobody knows about
shoes that equate actually it depends
how you look at it we were more or less
the the workers the maintenance people
the Hubble Space Telescope so yours we
didn't look through the telescope
mechanics it but our smart people here
on earth all the astronomers for example
Adam riess and a group of other
astronomers won a Nobel Prize the theory
of dark energy and dark matter came out
of Hubble oh wow observation photos what
you fell out of we fixed so we were more
like the repair people but you know
there's astounding discoveries that were
made but didn't you like some like a
syllabus to see what we like our own fun
stuff like did you go like yeah we're
gonna fix the Hubble and while we do
this here's some like stakes and shoes
and
see how rabbits a how we have a mission
you know candies and steadily yeah we
did our own little experiments but you
know I play we played baseball's bass
them yeah did you get walk in space and
play baseball no not it I did I walked
in space and I played baseball
separately Hey well now you play
baseball inside the cabin but we we did
we did participate in some human subject
tests but the big science objectives for
us where to get Hubble fix it discovered
dark matter to discover some really cool
stuff they've now around the term dark
matter dark energy ever throws it around
like it's just everything knows if
that's an extraordinary now but mass is
the goal prize-winning stuff this is
Startalk